have you checked housing prices lately I
checked six seven times a day and houses
are stupid expensive at first I assumed
houses cost so much because they have
buried treasure in the backyard but the
sentencing judge at my trespassing trial
said most houses don't have treasure at
all fortunately jail provided me ample
time to learn about economics and the
meaning of friendship yeah you've been
sold for a pack of cigarettes yup that's
how currency works even here in prison
there are markets and scarce Goods yeah
you can solve for half a pack of
cigarettes housing prices are a function
of supply and demand when we reduce the
available stock of housing because of
supply and demand the price of housing
increases so essentially
build more houses houses will be cheaper
restrict how many houses are available
housing becomes more expensive the
number one culprit of driving up house
prices land use regulations zoning laws
establish where people can build and
can't build homes and what types of
homes they can build
kind of like SimCity there's a
commercial section over here a
industrial section over there
Hooverville that away some light
residential zoning red light districts
here here secret labor camp we work and
so forth it's a fun system if you enjoy
playing SimCity but in real life it
artificially limits the available space
for building houses we only have so much
land maybe someday we'll get around to
conquering a lazier defenseless Planet
but until then cities which are where
most people live have a limited amount
of space in which to build if zoning
laws only allow Builders to construct 10
new houses all homes will cost more than
if the city allowed Builders to
construct a thousand houses in 2022 15
percent of New York City's commercial
properties were vacant a lot of
employees have gone remote lessening the
need for office space some buildings are
just old and unappealing to prospective
businesses which are like hermit crabs
with neckties there is demand for
housing in New York City a lot in fact a
building with a lot of vacant offices
might be inclined to mix and match
converting vacant floors into Apartments
but they can't legally do that even if
the whole building is vacant everybody's
working from home in their pajamas
nobody's wearing pants the owners can't
convert it to housing even if nobody
wants to work in the building and
thousands of prospective tenants would
love nothing more than a one bedroom
overlooking the famous green lady
holding an ice cream cone they still
could not legally demolish the old
office complex and build housing or
maybe a developer wants to tear down an
old building design for one or two
families to build a skyrise that
accommodates hundreds even if it's
already zoned for residential use the
building can't be altered if it's
designated as historic picture New York
City
in your mind
now think of all the wonderful old
buildings that would be a cultural loss
if demolished
how many do you suppose there are
500 a thousand
if I were designating historical
buildings I'd use much less expansive
criteria such as
would my mom be excited to eat brunch
inside of this thing how potentially
vengeful are the spirits of this
graveyard or did George Washington's
sleep mate or fight here historical
designations are often just weaponized
zoning to help increase property value
for nimby's
we
nope try again that's not how you spell
that
close enough right anyway these laws are
used by nimby's to drive up property
value or keep nice views in Los Angeles
denizens worried that a new apartment
building would block their view of a
clock so they advocated for designating
everything in between as a historic
district a significant amount of zoning
laws in the United States are
restrictions homeowners put in place on
other people's property to ensure that
their own property maintains or
increases value great if you're the
homeowner but sucks if you want to build
a home remember New York
the skyline we all know and love has
been grandfathered into the city code
today 40 percent of the buildings in New
York couldn't be built because they're
too tall or have too many apartments or
have too many businesses in them to be
clear I think it makes sense to have a
little zoning if you wanted to make
regulations saying no playgrounds next
to a wolf Puck fair enough cities need
regulations to deal with negative
externalities like harmful chemicals
noise from clangy Factory things or
smells from smelly clingy Factory things
basically loud things smelly things and
dangerous things but most American
cities go a step further rather than
pushing Smog or wolf Parks out of
heavily populated areas American cities
legally forbid heavily populated areas
to exist at all because American cities
Zone away density homeowners want their
property to be as valuable as possible
so relying on supply and demand they
artificially restrict Supply through
minimum lot size I think tiny houses are
cute for example isn't that cute it's
about 250 square feet if you bought half
an acre of land you could build 87 tiny
houses like that on it but other
homeowners in the neighborhood would
worry that a tiny house Village would
hurt property value build a bunch of
tiny houses want a bunch of Hobbits move
into the neighborhood we don't want them
attracting dragons so the nimbys talk to
the city and get a minimum lot size
established now it's illegal for me to
build more than one home on the law the
neighborhood keeps its big leafy yards
and the single house I can legally build
is probably going to be a lot larger
than the proposed tiny home which will
keep property value high that Hobbit
example might seem silly but something
similar happened with cities all across
America throughout the 20th century
racist homeowners didn't want black
people to move into their neighborhood
so they zoned massive parts of town for
single family dwelling units to ensure
no apartment buildings could Sprout up
while America is less racist and
arguably more prohibit than it was a
century ago those zoning restrictions
persist it's illegal to build anything
other than a single family home in 75
percent 75 percent of the residential
land and many American cities not
duplexes triplexes or God forbid
apartment buildings not buildings which
could house lots of families thereby
increasing Supply and bringing down
prices can only build houses
check out this map I stole you may think
this is weirdly sexual in nature but
it's actually Minneapolis Minnesota so
we're both right all the pink gunky bits
are places you can't legally build
anything other than a single family home
meaning you can't erect apartment
complexes meaning we are legally
abolishing density therefore
artificially creating scarcity which
drives up housing prices or here take a
look at this one this may look like a
rugby injury but it's actually Seattle
those pink spots that's where
multi-family housing is illegal you can
only build houses there or how about
this 85 percent of Sandy Springs Georgia
is this Sandy Springs Georgia or Sandra
Springs from Georgia my ex-girlfriend
it's Sandra
can I um
excuse me
hey Sandra it's Heaton
triplets huh what do you want to
uh
uh I don't know I just found out about
this I'll tell you what we won't do you
want to know we won't do
live in a multi-family dwelling unit in
Arlington Texas
because Sandra Texans don't really
believe in property rights they believe
in zoning other people Sandra hold on
you got to say your thing I get to say
because my things are important too I
have a very important job I do important
things I'm changing the world
finally cities are stacking regulations
and codes onto new construction
environmental impact fees tree removal
fees ensuring rain gutters are a
particular length and so forth these may
be worthwhile environmental policies but
by tacking them onto new construction we
also drive up construction costs they're
not free a study from the housing
research firm Zellman and Associates
calculated that local impact fees have
climbed 45 since 2005 to an average of
twenty one thousand dollars per home
across 37 major markets by putting their
burden primarily on new construction we
shift society's costs away from everyone
and onto people trying to build new
homes which not surprisingly makes those
homes more expensive now at this point
you might say Heaton that's all well and
good trying to make houses cost less by
increasing their supply terrific great
go do that but shouldn't the government
also be building affordable housing that
is a worthwhile conversation to have you
can make a good argument that cities
should build x amount of housing for the
chronically homeless which is more
Humane and cheaper than relying on
hospitals police and jails but
ultimately even if your solution to the
housing crisis is some version of
government building projects it won't
matter until we defang rampant
overzoning the biggest thing we could do
as a nation right now to lower the cost
of housing is just to sweep away all the
needless land use laws that are
specifically designed to increase the
value of housing minimum lot sizes
single-family use occupancy overzoning
and weaponized permitting schemes
whatever government steps you think are
a good idea it all has to begin with
land use reform I for one am not afraid
of more neighbors I like neighbors I
want more neighbors what I don't want
are more nimbies
sure yeah
[Music]